[Music]
hello welcome to the pretty intense
podcast I am your host Danica Patrick
and today we have an extremely special
guest someone that I've been following
for years and years his work within the
realm of trauma childhood and parenting
disease has just always blown me away
and his name is Gabor mate he has a new
book called The Myth of normal a book
that we start off by him explaining why
it took him over 10 years to write it
how much information he's collected over
that time and where he needed to get to
emotionally I think that Society at this
point in time needs a book like this the
myth of normal because what is normal
and
um and it shouldn't be the way that we
see it right now or should it be
different Gabor really challenges the
institutions the patterns the
mechanisms that have led us to the place
that we are right now and so we talked
about you know childhood parenting
talked about relationships when we
talked about Society what creates trauma
he's a he's just a really deep thinker
he's very honest and he shared so many
Amazing Stories I'm just grateful that
he got to the point where he could write
this book because it's everything that
we need so enjoy this really deep dive
with Gabor and thanks for listening if
you like what you hear please hit
subscribe and hit the bell for
notifications when we have another
episode come out or another clip or any
of those magical little bits that we put
out there for you guys let's talk about
what those myths of being normal really
are how are you anyway you have been on
an absolute media Terror
yeah I mean sort of the book launch
started in Vancouver British Columbia a
week ago Sunday and then I went to New
York for four days
I did a workshop here in La yesterday
and I you know yeah it's on a bit of a
tear but I can't complain because when
you spent 10 years working on a book
you're very glad when you have a chance
to get out and talk about it you know
yeah well that that that is something
that came through so many times in the
interviews is just how long this book
has been sitting and waiting for you to
write it and that it was difficult to
step into that and also it's everything
you've wanted to say so like what was
that what was that what was the issue
that held you back from writing it and
then was there a moment an event
something that tipped it over and got
you to sit down and I don't know if you
put a pen to paper or you put your
fingers through a keyboard but what
started the process
well what actually happened was that I
mean
um Gathering material for 10 years now
and I collected some like 25 000
different scientific papers and articles
newspaper reports Journal
articles
read a lot of books interviewed a lot of
people
and I had a contract to write the book
and I just thought no this is too much
you know I can't do it I've
just beyond me
and what it really was is I was so I've
kept myself so busy because of my work
hours and that there was no space in my
brain to
to generate something new and something
has installed as this and so it was
after a holiday with my wife in Costa
Rica which had a beautiful relaxing time
I was sitting in a hotel in San
Francisco having breakfast when all of a
sudden
this new title of method normal just
flooded into my brain
yeah a new inspiration a kind of a new
vision the other the other issue was
that when I first started writing the
book my own healing hadn't got
that Far Side a bit more of a morose
view of things so the book that I've
written now is very different than the
book I would have written then it's just
I didn't see the possibility of healing
I I saw it for others but not so much
for myself and so that's
that negativity kind of infused the
original version of the book which this
one so I had to get in other words I
just didn't I had to get to a certain
place of Peace Within Myself and some
space around it for the book to emerge
and that's that's what happened
well there was two things that I thought
of as you were talking one you said that
you had a very relaxing trip in Costa
Rica and for someone that has an issue
with you said working too much you
finally relaxed and then I also comes to
a question that I wanted to ask you
about whether or not
we can meet someone Beyond or treat
someone beyond the level at which we've
healed or where we're at emotionally as
in if we don't love each love ourselves
can we love another
um things so I'd say I found there seems
like there's a magic potion there
between like being able to relax being
almost the indicator that you had gotten
to a point that you were healed enough
to write it is that right well I think
it works both ways um some of us there's
this valve of compassion and love that
sometimes just it opens outwards but not
inwards and so you can help a lot of
people now you can't help them as much
as you could if you were fully healed
yourself or more healed that's true but
I've often had the experience I mean
this is my fifth book not
my other four have been published you
know all over the world and I get these
emails from everywhere thank you you
book
changed my life and my response often
was thank you maybe I should read it
myself you know in other words so humble
well no because because people describe
Transformations that they had
that I hadn't experienced myself so to
some extent it's possible to help others
but you can take them
as far as you could
unless you're further along the journey
yourself so I think it does work both
ways how is that where do you find that
information or that ability to connect
to those spaces of healing and
transformation having not been able to
feel it yourself
you know it reminds me of something that
the great Russian dancer nujinski said
about a hundred years ago he was a belly
dancer kind of the baroshnikov and
nurave of Zone day and and he was asked
about these incredible leaps that he was
able to perform during a belly sequence
and he said
when najinski is there it can't happen
it's something that just flows through
him but he's he's
he doesn't create it it's like comes
through him and so I think some people
have I have that ability to some extent
to to channel something that comes
through me to other people or to an
audience that maybe I haven't grasped
myself and nor can I grasp it you know
um so I think that's what happens is
that there's a kind of channeling that
I'm not the only one that way I know
others you know
who can talk well and can help others
and something can come through them
that's very healing and transformative
even but they haven't got there
themselves and that's always sad
you know I don't recommend it but it's
possible you know I think that's what
happens like what is that what is that
that someone in this life comes in with
this ability to connect and
come out of your own experience and body
into another space another another
energy uh what is that
well it's a mystery isn't it you know
you see it a lot actually you see it in
artists and uh performers
something comes through them
that they can't manifest something even
joyful and creative and and very
positive
but in their own lives they can't
manifest at all but when they're when
they're performing it it just happens
I think that has to do with us some
people are born very sensitive and they
just connect
more naturally with something outside
themselves
[Music]
um
I also think it comes through
a certain degree of suffering that maybe
you've worked through
you know
and and also I think you know
this is getting maybe more mystical than
I usually would venture into but
there is a truth there's a larger Unity
that there's a Oneness that whether we
know it or whether we don't know it but
we all belong to and I can manage this
it manifests itself through us even if
our conscious mind and even our
personalities can't quite get a hold of
it I think I think that's what that's
what's going on yeah that's beautiful I
would agree is there anything that you
do that gets you into that space more or
allows for more of that to come through
um a situation you put yourself in or a
practice that you have
[Music]
um
I'm not disciplined enough to go to
regular practice I mean I really do have
an 80 I really do have an add brain and
then it
it it's a challenge for me to meditate
or to do yoga regulate for example when
I do but I don't keep it up as much as I
know would be good for me
for me that has come through psychedelic
work actually
um which is
not the same I mean as as just coming to
it
more spontaneously but that is that has
put me in those spaces sometimes and
that's been helpful for me
no I'm glad you brought that up because
I I definitely want to ask you about
that
um I've done it myself a few different
times
um Ayahuasca psilocybin yeah MDMA very
varying degrees of healing tools
um
man is this the future of therapy is
this the future of
psychology and growth and meeting
ourselves I think that a loss of self is
something you've said has been is a
problem in society and what keeps us
disconnected from from ourselves that
loss of self through the environment
that we're in these days so psychedelics
essentially bring you back to that and
go beyond it into spaces my experience
that you don't you didn't know were
there
um aspects of yourself truths that you
wouldn't have always Otherwise Known so
it seems like this could be a really a
big healing tool moving forward
yes so in this book The Myth of normal I
do have one chapter on psychedelics
which is probably appropriate so out of
33 chapters one is on psychedelics
because I don't want to put my ex all
into the Psychedelic basket so like on
the one hand
it can be very powerful and the first
time I did I asked maybe 12 13 years ago
I just experienced this pure love that
had I that had never accessed before you
know I literally had tears of love
uh rolling down my cheeks and uh I
thought I'd arrived somewhere well
because my family could tell you two
days later
I had to Glimpse something but I hadn't
arrived anywhere you know so uh and I've
I've LED retweets and I've helped people
with psychedelics and I've done
you know with myself I think they're a
great potential I don't think they are
the answer I don't think they are the
future I think the future has to be far
more with the transformation of people
and of social structures and and the
culture itself we can't rely on one
particular modality but the second to do
is they offer they show your great
potential and
um
what shows up is As you say is things
you weren't aware of it's almost like
there's a membrane between our conscious
minds and all the stuff we carry in our
subconscious
and the psychedelics remove the membrane
it's almost like you can have a waking
dream and experience
overage or the hatred maybe all the
terror all the fear but all the beauty
all the love all the Oneness all the
unity all the joy all the presence that
is in US
and but be awake for the experience and
be able to get a relationship to it uh
psychedelics I think as you also suggest
I think
can put in touch with that Unity that
we're all a part of but we're hardly
aware of it most of the time in fact in
this culture which is all about
competition and aggression greed and
acquisition we are almost
societally
propagandized into forgetting that unity
and that Oneness and that
intercorrection Executives can open that
up beautifully
but
then there's the rest of Life yeah and
what you glimpsed and experienced in the
secular space
the question is how to make those same
values which
puke can attain with us like how to make
those values work in our regular lives
in our social lives in our culture and
that that's the question that goes Way
Beyond psychedelics I think
sure that's culture and society and the
patterns that they keep us in outside of
ourselves that pull us back in so
quickly
um
yeah what do you think is the what do
you think holds us back the most when we
come out of that like we get into these
spaces we feel love and then we get back
into our routine
like if there were a few things to
change what would it be like when you
came back what what did you think this
this this is this is what Society pulls
me back into the heart with with the
hardest
I think there's two forces pulling us
back into our ordinary less Unitarian
less connected self
one is just
um our personalities are formed in the
first place
which is very often in my contention the
result of responses to traumatic events
or traumatic pressures that happen to
children in this Society quite a lot
and so we formed these defensive
structures that we call the personality
and the personally doesn't want to give
up too easily because
when stuff happened in shelter that
makes you defensive it makes you afraid
or makes you
um disconnected
um those structures have been living in
you and dominating your life
depending how old you are for decades
they don't just disappear they don't
just dissolved you might get a momentary
respite from them in a psychotic space
but they haven't all of a sudden
evaporated and the Buddha talked about
what he called our habit energies so our
habit energies are the thoughts and
emotional patterns and
psychological structures that
are ingrained in our brains and our
nervous systems in our bodies and it
just reassert themselves almost
automatically then there's society which
is
all about
how we look to others and what other
people think of us and how we fit in and
how we please others or how to compete
with others and
then we go back into that world and so
it's no wonder that between the inner
habit energies that have dominated our
lives and then the external pressures we
quickly can lose the glow of that
spiritual or psychological insight that
we gained either through some spiritual
experience or through secular like sort
with an encounter with nature perhaps so
it's difficult to maintain that and then
above all there's what my friend the
psychiatrist Dan Siegel calls the
um the the myth of the solo self and
like we all fundamentally every ego
believes that it's a UNIF that it's a
separate unit
sufficient unto itself you know and we
believe in our separateness and in this
culture
reinforces that belief of course so it's
it's not an easy not an easy path
brings me back to um so I did a a little
bit of a hero's dose of psilocybin I
took five grams and it took me to
a really distant place and I went really
far away but one of the main things that
happened in the experience was that and
it was facilitated this was this was
with a facilitator and yeah
um was that
I knew that being human wasn't real and
but I wanted to be human
yes and so the first thing that I had to
agree to in order to build constructs to
get back to being human was I had to
agree to the mind
yeah that's right and I was like great
okay perfect fine let's go I want I want
to see my family again I want to see my
dogs again
um because in the early part of the
experience I didn't know how I was ever
going to be human again because I knew
it wasn't real and so so yes I had to
agree to the mind which in you know for
for me felt like the ego it felt like
the stories this was the lie because
being human wasn't real the mind was the
LIE which is the stories and the ego
yeah have you ever experienced anything
like that not personally but I can tell
you about somebody I talked to yesterday
you might know the name her name her
name is Anita marjani do you know that
name no
no okay another majority
wrote a book
um
called dying to be me and
um here was a woman who no in my view of
illness as a physician I've noticed who
gets sick and who gets chronic illness
and malignancy it's people who really
repress themselves in order to fit in
with others and that's
defensive response to Childhood
experiences Anita was one of these
people
and she had this terminal lymphoma
station lymphoma she was in a coma and
the doctor said this is in you know she
lives in L.A which is why I'm right
um she was in a coma and the doctors
have her telling her family to prepare
for her death within a few hours
and then Anita had this out of body
near-death experience
where she saw her whole life where she
saw her she had never been herself her
whole life that's why the title of a
book dying to be me it took near death
to make her become herself
but then she was in this realm where she
could have chosen to stay there
but she had to make a decision
do I stay there in this beautiful realm
of unity and Light
or do I come back into my mind and my
body and sounds very similar to your
experience you have that choice too she
said I made she said I made a choice to
come back no
within four or five days early lymphoma
had disappeared and within a few days
she was out of hospital and she's never
been sick since
now this is not totally unheard of and I
can sort of explain it in certain
physiological ways but the point is she
was facing that same choice that you had
made and she just decided to come back
and back of course means coming back to
the body come back into the mind now her
life is very different than it used to
be prior to her experience but she still
faces the challenges of
coming up against the personality and
the ingrained habits and all that stuff
so no she had that experience on the
verge of death you had it with the
psalocybin but they sound very similar
you might want to talk to her sometime
that would be very interesting it was
there was a choice I didn't add that
part to the story but essentially I was
in this what felt like Baseline reality
being like a waveform so it's just kind
of waveform and there was an energy or a
group of entities a voice and knowing
and this energy was like come this way
and it was as if there was this light
shaft that went up like energy very
light light energy shaft they're like
come on if you you know if you want to
be an ascended Master you have to lose
you have to let go of form that was what
they said and I was like whoa no no no
no no are you ready for that I don't
want to go there yet I'm I mean my
family my dogs my my friends and so I
chose not to
um but it's very interesting because I
I've talked to a couple of people and
they
that is a part A lot of times of plant
medicines is there's a choice with a big
enough I think a big enough dose is
somewhat necessary I hate to tell you
but I've heard of those triple than what
triple what you had you know wow how was
that well that's another story but I'm
gonna tell you something else I I heard
you say some somewhere that
relationships are some of the most
important learning that you do you know
and so my wife actually had one of those
experiences that you described not with
psychedelics
and not in the verge of death but we
were having a very difficult time in our
relationship some decades ago and she
was really suffering and stuff raining
was there any [ __ ] to do with I was
showing up or not showing up and she
surrendered to it she just at some point
she says all I can do is surrender to it
and she had this Direct Energy of her
form disappearing everything just
becomes energy
everything was unitary
she saw my perfection she saw the
Perfection the Perfection of his husband
who was not being very kind or very nice
at that time so she had a very similar
experience so what I'm saying is that
these experiences are of unity and
energy Pure Energy you know I can't
describe it as articulately as she can
but she did a that experience so what
I'm saying is that clearly there's
something about us that they're usually
we're not in touch with that is capable
of going to those spaces
um and it does not necessarily take
psychedelics in her case
nothing like that was involved at all
yeah yeah so well the other story didn't
include psychedelics either it was a
near-death experience but it wasn't uh
it was there was no substance taken to
create that altered state I agree What's
it gonna take
I just have this theory that there's so
much going on in the world there's
propaganda there's lies there's fake
news there's all these different things
and we how do we know what to trust and
so the feeling I have is that we're
being called to
learn how to use our inner guidance
system call it our conscience our
intuition in order to be able to be
essentially the lie detector for
ourselves
what do you think about that well I I
think there's a lot of Truth in it no
question is
what makes that so difficult so
um
I do think that in this Society
the way we raise children and the way we
live it alienates for alienists from our
our true nature
um see you never met an animal
who's not in touch with their gut
feelings and their intuitions that's so
true you know and
and human beings as they evolved over
millions and hundreds of thousands of
years they lived very much in intuition
in connection with their bodies I mean
if you're a hunter-gatherer which is
what we were for most of our existence
how long do you survive out there in the
wild if you're not in touch with you got
feelings not very long so the question
then is what happens in modern society
that separates us from ourselves right
and that's where I think trauma comes in
so that drama for me is is the essence
of it is a disconnect from yourself and
and that could be caused by people you
know terrible things that happen such as
abuse and and so on or neglect where
it's too painful to be in your own body
so you're disconnected the way of
survival
which to me is at the basis as a
physician in my view it's at the base of
a lot of physical illness and mental
illness as well
um but generally Javier raised children
is like one of the needs of children
one of the essential needs of children
which we don't appreciate is the freedom
to experience all their emotions
now in this Society a lot of parents are
advised that certain emotions are
allowed in children some are not so
children get the message very early that
if I'm fully myself if I'm completely
myself I won't be acceptable but they
have to disconnect from themselves they
know to be acceptable to their families
and to their schools and to their
culture
and so when you ask the question about
what will it take I think what will take
is for us to recognize this or
traumatized we are or how disconnected
we are and how we live our lives in this
particular society where we raise our
children
actually disconnects people from their
two cells and then it becomes a real
struggle to reconnect
and sometimes it takes
some very difficult experiences to to
wake us up to just how disconnected we
have become from ourselves and uh
so I think it's a large social question
that you're asking no
yes people can work on it and they have
to on the individual level on individual
level it's my responsibility to
connect with my gut feelings and my
authentic self and I can't wait for
society to do it for me but I think it
has to happen both on the individual and
on a social level as well I mean have
you met it one day old baby that wasn't
in touch with themselves right you know
so in other words something happens
doesn't it to be born that way and then
something happens to disconnect us and
we have to look at what are the things
that disconnect us from ourselves and
how do we reverse that
great tragic trend
the environment that we raise kids is so
much different than it was in times of
the past where there was a community
there was Elders grandparents Aunts
Uncles cousins there was a whole
community and so now it's you get one or
two hopefully people that are imprinting
or projecting their own patterns onto
you and what they think is good or
normal uh and in the past there used to
be 20. yeah how big of a problem is that
well you just summarize several chapters
of my book
um
so there's a story I like to tell that I
read recently
um in my book The Myth of normal I quote
a psychologist her name is darcia narves
and she
now retired as a professor at Notre Dame
University and she studied
hunter-gatherer groups and and
Indigenous people how they parent and
they parented exactly the way you
described in communities children had
many parents I mean they knew their
biological parents and had a special
issue with them but they're really
parented by the whole community so they
felt very safe very contained
um very connected that's her that's what
evolved as human beings and we lived
that way for hundreds of thousands of
years
almost a blink of an eyeball really
um and modern society the separation is
getting worse and worse and worse
[Music]
Garcia just written the new book which
will be published next year uh for which
I wrote the forward and uh
it's called evolved nest and the evolved
Nest is
the context in which we evolved as human
beings
and she Compares us to other animals so
the story that I loved in her new book
which is out next year you know when
enough and mother gives birth you know
what happens this is incredible so when
the mother elephant goes into labor
all the other mothers stand in a circle
and when the newborn hits the ground
they all stroke the newborn with their
trunks wow so birth itself was a
communal experience wow you know and
that's certainly meant to be the latest
for human beings
so in the book I have a chapter on
prenatal experiences we know already
that stresses on pregnant women
translate into stress on the baby that
in a way that changes the baby's
physiology and brain development affects
it in negative ways in ways that you can
trace decades later now how well do we
look after pregnant women I mean as a
physician I was trained to do the blood
tests and the ultrasounds and the
physical examinations maybe talk about
nutrition nobody ever suggested that I
talked to a woman about her emotional
states and how stretching us and what
kind of supportion is healing then
there's the birth process
and again you know I delivered a lot of
babies as a physician thank God for
modern obstetrics so I'm not here to
military against the you know the
Miracles of modern medicine black we've
carried it way too far we approach Earth
as a disaster waiting to happen and we
interfere with it mechanize it and
lights and machines and noise and we're
actually interfering with the natural
process that's meant to
help the infant and the mother Bond and
with their interference we're actually
already interfering with the mother
infant Bond wow then here's the fact
that in the United States where we're
speaking right now I'm Canadian but in
the U.S here 25 of women have to go back
to work within two weeks of giving birth
but that amounts to a massive
abandonment of infants because that
infant physiologically and emotionally
needs to be with their mom for much
longer we create the separation right
from the beginning right
you get we get it wrong right from the
beginning
culture and Society just honoring
working hard and sacrificing and you
know just prioritizing everything other
than
you know children and well-being and
mental health it's all about status and
money keeping your job getting a
promotion well my friend the um I don't
know if you know his name is Rafi he's a
children's singer
um he's a real famous children's
Troubadour he's sitting at the first
Clinton inauguration and it's just a
world famous children's singer
um generations of kids have grown up
singing his songs and he was telling me
that he was laying there bed at night
maybe 10 15 years ago and all of a
sudden he he sat at a bolt up right and
his thought child honoring came into his
head and he said what if pair of society
then honors children if we just ask
ourselves what does it to create a world
that honors the real needs of children
we will do everything differently yeah
the foods we sell kids the the products
that you know we wouldn't be
pushing addictive devices on them at an
early age we wouldn't be separating from
the mothers at two weeks of age
just that very question of what would it
take to create a world that honors the
needs of children
turns out
that's how Aboriginal people indigenous
people actually lived if they lived in
the way that honored children
well I know you've spoken so much about
children and
um holding them when they're crying and
yeah
um taking care of their needs
um so what is it that creates a securely
attached child
sure well I I think you told me you have
dogs is that right I do what does it
take to create a secure attachment with
a dog
I just yes I I actually just had
something come through last night that
was just honor what they want to do
honor what they want to do if she's
picking my hand up just pet her if she
drops the ball in front of me throw the
ball like yeah those are her loves and
that's essentially her language well so
so
there's certain brain circuits that we
share with all mammals including dogs
okay now
um and those brain circuits that's our
biological psychological nature they
dictate that children have certain
essential needs what I call irreducible
needs needs that if they're not met they
lead to a distorted development and and
lack of health so what are the
irreducible needs of children
they're not that different from
irreducible needs of other amounts first
of all
um an attachment relationship with
parents that's absolutely secure uh
where the child is just welcomed that
you are the person that we want
you are the person you want in this
world
secure attachment
unconditional
um
you don't have to be pretty you don't
have to be smart you don't have to be
compliant you don't have to be cute you
don't have to be clever
you're just you're the one we want
that's the first one
the second the second point is within
that relationship the child has to be
able to rest
by arrest we mean or I mean or
my psychologist friend who gave me this
concept means the child shouldn't have
to work to make the relationship work
because the relationship should be
unconditional so in a lot of homes
parents love their kids it's not a
question do they love them but if the
parents are having stresses and problems
the child will very often take on the
responsibility of trying to make it
better by fitting in by being nice by
being compliant by suppressing their own
feelings
this is typical in homes where there's
alcoholism by the way a child could work
to make the relationship work with the
parent a child so it shouldn't need rest
where they don't have to work to make
the relationship work yeah so the third
need I have already mentioned which is
the freedom to experience all of our
emotions and be held through those
emotions a lot of parents in this
Society there's a lot of behavior
psychologists and parenting so-called
experts who tell parents your neutrality
is angry give them a time out in other
words what you do is you threaten the
child with the loss of what's most
important to them which is that
attachment relationship and you say to
them this attachment is conditional if
you have emotions that I don't like
and if you manifest those emotions
you're going to be deprived of me which
is your biggest need
so then a child is in this dilemma okay
I'm a two-year-old frustrated little
angry little kid has kids off and I but
if I'm in my anger
my parents will reject me
that's not what the parent intends to do
but that's the effect of the time out
right
yeah so the child wouldn't suppressed
himself disconnect them from theirselves
in order to maintain the relationship so
the third need is the freedom to feel
all our emotions
the fourth one is what you mentioned
about dogs we have a need to play
spontaneous fee play out there in nature
that's wired into our brains play it
turns out according to all the research
is much more important for brain
development than cognitive learning
absolutely so there's all this stuff
with Baby Einsteins and teaching kids uh
all this stuff early and you know video
games to
promote brain development it's all
nonsense what promotes brain development
is healthy spontaneous play that's why
animals play that's why your puppies
play that's why Bear Cubs play
and in our society we've almost totally
deprived kids of these spontaneous
players So when you say what it takes to
develop a healthy child meet those four
conditions and you'll have it
emotionally healthy balance connected
grounded confident child
so that play is not being is not taking
and putting something on them like
here's a toy here's a Baby Einstein game
it's allowing the child to organically
naturally lead into something that
they're interested in whether it be
rolling on the floor or climbing a tree
or whatever it may be it's their own
innate Direction that's what you're
saying yeah you know a kid who is um
still connected themselves you give them
a stick in a puddle and they're busy the
whole day you know you know it will go
here's my little boat swimming in the
pot you know in the ocean you know but
but we've taken that away from kids you
know and and from that point of view the
digital technology that young children
are exposed to is simply toxic it's just
toxic for them and it actually
interferes with their brain development
what should be the rule on that because
in my opinion it sure looks like you
give a kid
new technology that's touch and they
know what to do with it right away it's
almost like they had kids and they're
sort of you know primitive natural
instinctual brains helping lead
technology so it sure seems like it
because they know what to do so what's
the right rules for that well in in
writing the book I talked to
um a couple of experts on this including
um
um
a psychiatrist called shimikan who the
Harvard trained psychiatrist who studied
this question and has written about it
digital technology and she points out
that the digital companies actually
Target these Gadgets in a way to
activate those circuits in the brain
that are most prone to get addicted in
children
they call that neural marketing neural
marketing targeting the nervous system
this isn't conspiracy theory this is
very surreality you know and uh
I
I would say when to induce
the screens and digital material to kids
well let's ask the same question about
other things we might all agree I mean
unless you have an alcoholism tendency
that alcohol or a glass of wine can be a
pleasant social lubricant and people
have used it for but would you give it
to a one-year-old
you know and and and we also agree that
sex is both beautiful and necessary but
you don't want five-year-olds engaging
in it right so so the answer is you
introduce it when the children are
emotionally mature enough to handle it
hmm and that's not so much a
chronological thing as a your
relationship with the child plus secures
the child how much influence can you
have on the child in regulating how much
digital screen they use but when you
give it to them early they just got
addicted to it and you try to peel them
off it they'd be like they behave like
addicts and withdrawal
so that's the indicator is how do they
act and react when you give them a time
limit or take it from them if I was a
parenting now
I would not have a screen in my house
except in my office
until my kids are willing to their
school age years I'd have them play
outside I'd have been go hiking I'd have
them do all kinds of stuff and you know
what when you give them that won't fall
behind when you're introduce them they
catch up like that and if they're
grounded in themselves and
self-regulated then you can give them
their machinery and you're no longer
afraid that they'll be seduced by it
well you know the first thing to get cut
in school is like gym class now so and
art and art
that are the music in other words music
all the creative playful stuff but it's
Financial this is happening I talk about
this in the book this happened in Quebec
and Canada like doing covet they had to
cut certain things what do they cut they
got jammed they got art they cut music
now you ask people you ask most people
most adults compare the importance of
music in your life to the importance of
algebra what would they say oh my gosh I
play music all day every day it's helped
guide my energy
but educationally we get it all
backwards yeah we put the
intellectual and the left brain
cognitive I had the head of the
emotional right brain creative
again it's just a negative influence on
child development right
what are the I've always I've thought of
this many times there's a couple of
topics that fascinate me one of them is
children
um well both of these two topics that
fascinate me the most one being children
I don't have kids and the other one I
don't have either which is anxiety and
so I'm fascinated by them because I
don't understand them
um so one of the questions as my sister
has three girls I'm about to have her
fourth is yeah is of course what creates
a securely attached child but then also
and now I'm going to get to a question I
was going to ask you early early which
is
do we all have trauma
so
mass is something about anxiety first
since you mentioned it yeah we can talk
about that for sure with the trauma so
in our brains we have certain circuits
that we share with animal and animals
that I mentioned emotional Spirits for
anger we have one for caring or love
we have them for lust we have them for
play we have them for seeking we have
them for fear
um we also have a circuit for panic and
grief and the reason we have that is
because when a young child loses the
parent or the parental contact they
should experience panic and grief
sure because that will then make them
vocalize and cry for the parental
presence or should set the parent
running yeah support the child yeah
now in a culture
that tells parents not to pick up the
kids when they're crying
in order to sleep train them
that panic and grief circuit gets over
activated and in the culture of
disconnection when parents are less and
less because of this not because they
don't love their kids but because of the
stresses in their life and because of
the loss of community that you talked
about early in our conversation
adults are less and less available for
kids kids develop a lot of panic a lot
of anxiety so so if you look at what's
happening with children right now more
and more of them are being medicated for
anxiety and ADHD and self-harm and
problems and more and more children
actually are committing suicide
according to all the studies you know
there's something happening on a
cultural level that making their kids
very anxious and that's something is the
loss of connection to a nurturing Adult
Community you know so
now there was an article in the New York
Times three weeks ago as we speak now
front page article about this teenager
who's on 10 different psychiatric
medications
and this is a trend
in the United States especially
because if so lost the plot when it
comes to raising healthy children that
all we can try and do according well not
all but the dominant tendency is just to
diagnose kids with these disorders and
to medicate them rather than dealing
with what is making them so anxious in
the first place why can't they you know
no
to comment your question about trauma
then uh in this Society I mean the title
of the book is the myth of normal trauma
illness and healing in a toxic culture
and my contention is is that very few of
us Escape without being traumatized to
one degree or another now
to explain that I'd have to tell you
what what I see trauma has been because
if you think of trauma as only terrible
things happening
which they do happen to a lot of kids I
mean a lot of kids are abused physically
or emotionally or sexually there's
studies several studies not recently
that showed that just spanking kids can
be as traumatic as physical abuse right
right because of the way you register it
because the way the child registers it
that the people that
um the people that are meant to provide
him or her with safety are not hitting
them right confusing and traumatic for a
job so I'm not talking about
moral questions here I'm talking about
studies that are showing that even the
act of spanking if it happens over time
can a significant traumatic effects so
so trauma is what happens when terrible
things happen but if you look at the
word trauma itself what it means is it's
a wound it's a psychic wound and you can
wound kids not only by doing bad things
to them but also by not giving what they
need by depriving of their emotional
needs now for reasons that we already
talked about so many kids are wounded
when you don't pick up a child when
they're crying you're wounding them
because like any animal
that that Christ would apparent try and
tell a mother baboon not to pick up
their infant when they're crying
um try and tell a mother bear not to
respond to the infant's distress but we
tell parents this all the time
you know so that to me that's
traumatizing that ruins the side
psychologically so in this Society
I don't think I think there's a real
trauma spectrum and I think most of us
find ourselves on it some place or
another I certainly have but so do my
children because
problem with trauma is that if you're
not aware of it they haven't worked it
out you know beyond unwittingly pass it
on to the next Generation not because we
don't love them not because we're not
doing our best but because our best is
limited
by our own trauma so I think that
Society it's rare to see
um people who don't carry some degree of
time is that like a big T capital T
lowercase T kind of traumas where it
says things that are super that are much
more aggressive like rape or abuse
versus you know just taking a toy at the
wrong moment or not being picked up at
the right moment
um that that sort of the separation yeah
yeah yes or the scale or not not being
picked up
um not in the emotions
honored and recognized yeah not being
held and let's let's see a little kid is
upset and the parent unwittingly and
well-meaning this is get over it you
know no big deal
that's not what the child needs right
right he's not well it's projection
they need to be
have the experience that the parents can
stay calm and regulated to the child is
upset
react and hold the child through the
upset so the child learns that yeah I
can have suffer pain
and distress but it passes and I can
handle it so the children learn
self-regulation by the adults being
self-regulated and helping to regulate
the child because as you know
is again then Siegel the psychiatrist I
mentioned points out
the the child learns self-regulation by
employing the more mature circuits of
the adult brain
of the parent or themselves of the of
the the child uses the more mature
circuits of the parents adult brain to
help regulate their own immature brain
circuits well that can be really tricky
depending on what the parents like well
that's the whole point look their
parents are not supported and
self-regulated the child never develops
self-regulation so the point is not
coddling kids it's not coddling
it's just holding them and loving them
and helping them learn that they can
move through these difficult States and
they pass and they can handle it
that was what I was wanting to ask was
what are the tools that you give them to
navigate asking do we all have trauma
because say you create you know you
create a securely attached child and
they they are able to interface with the
world in a in a healthy way
um but and it seems from my experience
in
an opinion that everyone has trauma so
even when if you're able to raise those
unicorn children that are securely
attached I don't know where they are
um but I'm definitely not one of them
but what is it that you teach them as a
skill
um to be able to have the tools later in
life to be able to deal with a pattern
that's unhealthy that they want to get
out of which is essentially from for me
what has been my indication of a trauma
is a pattern that repeats that I just
finally notice yeah
well so you frame the question in terms
of what skills do you teach them and I
will push back on that one because it's
not a matter of skills
um
in this Society we really hung up on
teaching kids skills about how to do
this how to do that but you know what
Child Development actually proceeds on a
scaffolding of emotion so our emotional
self develops long before our cognitive
self that learns skills
[Music]
the right side of it and both in terms
of our Evolution as as animals but also
in terms of the individual development
of the human creature the right
emotional side of the brain devolves
before the left cognitive side
oh so it's not a matter of teaching
skills it's a matter of providing the
conditions where the emotional
scaffolding can develop in a secure and
strong way so that then the cognitive
skills can be built on top of it so it's
not a question of skill building or
skill teaching it's a question of
providing the right conditions for
healthy development
you know
later
the problem is for a lot of us because
we don't have that
secure grinding for emotional
development when something happens later
on in life that upsets us we're very
quickly thrown back into a very immature
State you know of being and that's
to speak with myself I mean the book
opens with an example of that you know
of myself not very young this is at age
71 reacting like I was a one-year-old
but that's because the emotional
architecture of my brain commit given
the conditions that I was living under
as an infant just
didn't develop the way out to have
that's not an excuse and it's not like I
can keep saying oh I can't help it it's
my responsibility to grow up at any age
you know but when you say to somebody
grow up
in a kind of critical way in the sense
you're being accurate because
but the question is what happened that
they didn't grow up in the first place
that wasn't their fault they didn't have
the conditions so what I'm saying is
it's not skill building or teaching it's
providing the conditions for healthy
development
um
I have heard you say that
children when they act out or start
screaming or have an emotional reaction
um
are acting out what they don't have
words for yet
well and I thought that was fascinating
and it made me wonder how do you help
give a child words and is that part of
the emotional conditioning or the safe
environment or is that part of the
is that part of the structure the
scaffolding is giving things words
well
let's take a very common with very
disturbing example of acting out but by
the way when usually when you talk about
kids acting out what are we talking
about
we're talking about kid being
upstreperous or oppositional or
aggressive or rude or disrespectful but
that's not what the phrase means
it's very simple English phrase acting
on means that you act out something that
you haven't got the words to say a
language so in a game of Charades where
you're not allowed to speak you have to
do
yeah I acted out or if you land in the
country where nobody spoke your language
and you wanted to portray hunger you'd
have to act it up well that's what kids
are doing and the question is what are
they acting on right what are they
acting on is their frustration and their
pain and their unmet needs
now in our society which is so Behavior
oriented so but how do you get the right
Behavior
all we try and do is to squelch the
behaviors that we don't like and to
promote the behaviors that we do like
but we focus the attention on behavior
modification of the child rather than a
child's emotional needs and healthy
development
and the two are not the same so let's
take a distressing example like bullying
and so Bullies Are nobody likes them
unless they're going to politics in
which case we elect them into power but
that's another story
but we won't go there right now
um but but
um
you know abilities is a real phenomenon
in our society and especially there's a
lot of bullying on the internet the kids
are really suffering now turns out when
you do the research on bullying
not only does bullying have unhealthy
consequences for the bullied the bully
themselves
equally goes up to be a kid with
physical and mental health issues
it's harmful for him as well or her as
well or them as well sure
now we can squelch the
behavior of bullying by so-called
Zero Tolerance policies that most school
districts have adopted but I looked a
little trampoline there was a major
study that looked at zero tolerance and
you know what the article was called
Zero Tolerance zero evidence
no evidence whatsoever that that works
the reason it doesn't work is it doesn't
address what the kid is acting on now
what is the kid acting out I need a need
for a need for connection I need to need
to be understood need to be held I need
I need to make I need to be important
yeah you know and why does the child
have a need to be important because the
adults in their lives are missing
the adults that need to make the child
they feel important not because of
what the child does or how they show up
it's just because they exist
does misting for those kids and you
always look at their backgrounds
something missing for them and so then
the the way you deal with bullying is
not through separating from them and
banishing them but by giving them strong
powerful loving adult attachments right
you know
in other words you don't respond to the
behavior you respond to the need and not
bully when you give them that
they transform very rapidly
very rapid you know and um
but we get it wrong we refocus on the
acting art which is the behavior rather
than what is being after dark right
which is the child's need a lot of
people who listen to this may think I'm
just trying to coddle and reward bad
behavior no I'm not I'm trying to
understand why it shouldn't behave the
way they do and how most effectively we
can help them to the benefit of the
child are the children in society and we
can only do that if we understand what
this is all about and why are so many
kids behaving that way these days
you mentioned one I think it was the
first rule
you had talked about a child being
wanted truly being wanted and
I have this theory on
whether it be music or an interview
any kind of human interaction that
there's some that just resonate with
people they resonate deeply a song can
move you an interview can grab you can
hit hit home and I just I have a I have
a theory that there's a frequency
carried with truth
and that we feel it and we know it maybe
the words aren't even that much
different but the energy is different
and so I wonder if that is one of the
big issues is whether or not a parent
and this is hard to probably it's very
hard to face if you're a parent I'm not
a parent
um do you really want that child
yeah like is the frequency of your
information in truth like are you just
doing the right thing just saying the
right thing but not feeling it and in
your experience have you noticed any
correlation between the truth of the
information and what they're saying and
they're not being a connection so
therefore the child doesn't feel it even
if you're doing the right things
you can love a child you can genuinely
love a child
but if at the same time there's any part
of you that
doesn't want some aspect of the child
the child would feel that
kids are very sensitive okay then
they'll be able they may not be able to
articulate it
but they'll sense it
and they'll experience it as a wound you
know yeah that's that's my view you know
um let alone children who are really not
wanted I mean I've known people who
more than a few person who
see under the influence of a psychedelic
will find themselves back in the womb
and sense their mother's stresses
you know and and the fact that they
weren't
actually welcomed and that's not the
parents fault maybe they weren't ready
to have a child maybe
um they were going through stresses that
that
um
well you know
in the book I called my wife
in one of the chapters and she's talking
to the the infant inside her belly with
one of her children
and and she's saying something like
my dear little child
all this adrenaline and all this
cortisol that I'm experiencing right now
is not because of you
and your dad wants to get to know you
will want you as much as I do but he
can't feel you moving and your belly
like I can
oh
and and
she was so right
because our relationship was at that
time a very difficult one and I was this
workaholic
Doctor Who wasn't just emotionally
available and in fact
could be very irritable I could be very
irritable and
emotionally
that's the unpleasant when I was at home
my wife was talking to the infant trying
to protect her from the impact of that
yeah yeah now we know from all kinds of
studies
as I mentioned earlier that that has an
impact on the internet already in the
womb
you know so
people are very sensitive and we are
interconnected and nobody's more
connected to anybody else than the young
child to the parent
so when the parent is going through
emotionally
the child will download on one level or
another and and I've had people
uh tell me about when they have
psychedelic experiences they they sense
the
pains and stresses and even when they
were not wanted by the band no no they
feel intense pain when they have that
experience
[Music]
um
yeah Goosebumps when you shared that
which to me is an indicator of yes it's
basically just my body saying yes that's
true
um when you share those those words that
your wife had said
um so yeah I'm I'm sure that that was
very important to the baby
um
like if we fast forward a little bit to
being an adult and being an adult
situations
what is it when someone
projects what's behind a projection
well I need to know what you mean by
projection
um just uh an opinion perhaps uh whether
or not you're doing something right or
wrong or
um
even just getting offended let's maybe
just say that like let's say let's just
flip it the other way what if somebody
said something to me and I get offended
what does that mean
that's a really interesting question I'm
just so uh I learned this somewhere this
is not original to me dot com
what if I complimented you right now on
your beautiful green hair what would be
your reaction
because he said beautiful but then green
and that's not accurate so
okay but what if I kept insisting that I
yeah
green hair what would you how would you
react to that
um
I might think that I obviously think
that you look through life in a diff
through a different lens but I'd
probably say thank you
yeah would you really but you wouldn't
but you would realize that I wasn't
seeing reality right of course yeah it's
not the same yeah at the very least I'm
colorblind yes exactly and you wouldn't
take it personally
or would you oh it seems so so left
field exactly
even though I was projecting something
totally untrue unto you but it wouldn't
have said you because you see that as my
problem yes okay however
I may say something else to you
that is equally a projection
but if it's a place where you've already
been wounded before then you'd get
offended
so
um if somebody calls me stupid
I don't get offended because I happen to
know that I'm pretty bright you know so
I know I have no insecure I have no
insecurity about my intelligence
but there are things that people can say
to me that'll get me offended because
maybe I've been wounded there before and
I don't quite
and some I buy into what they're saying
on some level and that's what offends me
so
um yeah the book is another way uh when
I'm offended uh it's because there's
something I mean got touched that I
haven't resolved yet otherwise I would
just see it there's a projection
you know I wouldn't take it personally
you know
um
you know that word indicator so it's an
indicator of a wound exactly that's
that's what I'm saying so we have this
word called trigger we're triggered
right yeah yeah so
and I often talk about this so
a trigger when you look at what a
trigger actually is in real
life it's a very small thing on a big
weapon which carries ammunition and
explosive charge
now if somebody triggers you it's only
because you're carrying the ammunition
and the explosive charge
that explosive charge where you explode
is precisely where you were wounded a
long time before when you haven't killed
the home yet otherwise you'll never be
triggered there's no ammunition or
explosive charge there somebody can pull
the trigger all they want nothing will
happen so so the question then is do we
put our attention
if we want to take responsibility for
ourselves if as adults we want to grow
up
and by the way most of ourselves have to
grow up
you know yeah
um
if you want to take responsibility for
our growth
we have to realize what is the explosive
charge enemy in other words what is the
wound that's not healed
and if I heal that wound that projection
will be seen as only a projection is
their problem
you know nothing to do with me
but
if I haven't healed that wound I'll be
triggered and then I'll blame the other
person for triggering me but actually
I wouldn't be the only one to point out
the first one to point out that these
people that trigger us they're our best
teachers
amen because they they let us know and
this happens in relationships all the
time doesn't it and lessons are never
easy no no they're not they're painful
uh so I guess it could be said that
projection is just it's very much the
same when you project something it's a
wound being poked essentially whether it
be the way something is done or the way
somebody said something maybe they said
something like hey what are you doing
and maybe it just triggers something
from childhood and that it puts you into
this space where you then project I'm
doing what I'm supposed to be doing
because maybe you as a child were
criticized for doing things wrong all
the time and so there's essentially the
projection is just a compliment to
triggering is that true well exactly and
so like I when I think about it
people questioning my intelligence would
never trigger me
right right but I can do but but I can
be triggered when I think about it so
when
when people
criticize me for saying things that I
never said
you know or when they interpret my words
in ways that are totally opposite to
what I intended
I noticed that if I'm honest with myself
that can set off something in myself why
because one of my childhood wounds was
not being seen for who I was the
children need to be seen
for exactly who they are yeah and I
wasn't
I'm not blaming my parents here I'm just
saying that's what happened yeah so when
I'm not seen
that can be can be that for me can be a
trigger no
somebody in that same is the function of
their own blindness
nevertheless their blindness can trigger
me because not being seen is one of my
core wounds so
their projection
and my wound kind of cooperate to create
the
the upset my mind is is wandering into
this space about
um
uh being
hurt in relationship but healing and
relationship and this idea around not
being able to be in a a relationship
until you're fully healed just laughing
because uh
will have been married 53 years this
year and uh
if we had waited to be fully healed we
still would never set The Wedding Date
you know
right no no it's an ongoing process and
as a matter of fact relationship I mean
as much as worked as much work as I have
done
um in therapy for myself and helping to
heal others and
whatever modalities you know in
spiritual work whatever uh the biggest
grunt for healing for me and it has been
a relationship you know and precisely
because
well in my view not only in my view
people always get together with somebody
at precisely the same level of
woundedness that they're at foreign law
you know if if I was this wounded and my
wife was this wounded we would never get
together it's like water finding its own
level but that also means can we then do
we have the Consciousness and the
commitment to growth and to truth
to want to heal together and support
them as difficult as it is and as
conflictual as it can get
do we have the commitment to grow
together
or do with respect the other person to
soothe our wounds
um and be upset when they don't you know
so I'd say that the strength of our
relationship has been that we've
as much as we've had difficulties and my
God nobody neither of us would say that
we're healed
but boy we've come a long way and and
it's been the biggest ground of our our
development is has been a relationship
no no don't wait until you're fully
healed if you do nobody would ever get
into a relationship how do I find
someone damn it
um I I mean obviously relationships are
such a big deal why is it that they why
are why is it that they seem to bring
out the most in us too like they are the
if this is only my experience and I
think that's it's probably at least a
lot of people's but why are
relationships these spaces where we
ultimately get some of our deepest
healings
because ultimate relationships
yeah well look Danica you're a very
public figure it's impossible not to
know something about your history of
relationships you know right right in
this culture that's the nature of the
celebrity culture that we live in you
know right
um
so let me ask you let me ask you a
question a couple of ways okay
um one is
in relationship that you've been in I'm
not asking
for names or anything like that but
did you ever have a sense
that something is not quite right
yeah you had a gut sense even before the
relationship got too far ahead
what did you do with that God sense
yeah
I
I said I did I felt like it was just uh
paranoia or yeah um it was you ignored
your own gut feelings yeah okay now that
ignorance we've got feelings
is what gets us into relationships that
ultimately can't work okay that's not a
question of how do I find the right
person it's how do you pay attention to
yourself that ignoring your gut feeling
is not anybody's fault it's nothing to
condemn or judge yourself for
that's an outcome of the child the
experience that I was talking about
where we get disconnected from ourselves
and so we no longer even know or pay
attention to our gut feelings so that's
the first part of my answer okay it's
just never mind looking for the right
person get to really know and trust
yourself
and don't let your mind and don't let
your mind dismiss what your
guts and your body and your heart is
telling you okay wow yeah so that's the
first answer the second answer is
that we always choose people and this is
not original to me there's a wonderful
family therapist called Harvel Hendrix
h-e-n-d-r-i-x and he's been an Oprah
multiple times in his order I wrote a
book called getting the love you want
any any points out this he wrote this
book after several failed relationships
by the way uh
yeah he points out that when we choose a
partner
you always choose somebody that'll carry
you some resonance over a childhood
relationship to our parents
because this kid you may think you're in
love with somebody because they're
handsome or pretty or witty or or
accomplished or fun to be with and
that's but physically attractive
that can be true
but that's the tip of the iceberg
underneath it is when you're a child
even if you're an abusive father
um or mother whose love did you most
want that abusive person's love is we
most wanted that means when you go out
there as an adult unconsciously
when your energy recognizes that abusive
potential in the other person you'll
immediately be attracted to them
that's who's love you wanted
to write that first wrong no no this is
this is unconscious yeah conscious this
is why you see so many women who are
abused in childhood end up in an abusive
relationship as adults and you think you
think they'd know better
but no it's because that's the energy
that they're drawn to because that's
where we're desperately looking for love
as children and that's where that's what
they're looking for love still as adults
so
uh it's not a question of finding the
right person it's a question of finding
the right person inside yourself yeah
well that was the Ayahuasca message the
first one it was that I was supposed to
find the relationship with myself not
with somebody else
that's what I'm saying
and when you do you find that religious
about there and I've seen that many many
times yeah yeah and that was the message
too is that you still get everything you
want but it has to be with you and you
first that's right
that's right
yeah yeah relationships they're very
interesting such great teachers well in
all of your work
um
I'm curious what surprised you the most
what is the best and worst surprise
maybe that's even better
what surprises me is how blind I can be
despite all I know that's that's always
the big surprise you know because I've
learned so much you know yeah and and
yet I can still be sometimes so blind
and that's the biggest surprise it's
always surprising when I think I know
something and I and then I know what I
thought wasn't right and and how I
experienced this
didn't really correspond to what
happened it was I was still projecting
my own interpretation on interpretation
into the experience so
that's the biggest surprise is how um
even after all the learning they've done
I can still
have a distorted sense of reality
of course hmm so much to learn what
about from other people have other
people surprised you or learning more
about
well absolutely look um in this book The
Mr normal I I talk about people who real
people that I know whose history
I'm familiar with who've gone through
incredible illness
uh to find themselves you know that
whose diseases
rather than killing them has led them
back to their authentic selves and or
even
sometimes as they died of their
illnesses and the most surprising thing
you can hear as a doctor
is when somebody says to you
um doc this illness and I used to work
in palliative care looking after
terminally ill people it's LOL yeah
Brooklyn Family Medicine but I have care
and then finally in addictions and in
palliative care but elsewhere in life in
my medical path as well
somebody would say to me Doc
this illness that's going to take my
life is the best thing that ever
happened to me
and you would think
how can anybody say that right nothing
is nothing
it's not the kind of learning I would
wish on anybody but they were talking
about is that through dealing with the
illness they actually got in full
contact with themselves and they knew
who they were for the first time and
that to them was more precious than the
extent of life itself now
I'm not advocating here I'm only telling
you you're asking what surprises me
to hear that is always a surprise
and more generally speaking
how suffering how people can be grateful
for suffering after they learned the
lessons that the suffering bestowed on
them
so I I quote this Greek playwright
escalus who 2500 years ago in one of his
plays said that the way Zoo saw the
master the God created us is that we
suffer suffer into truth and it always
surprises me impresses me how people can
suffer greatly through an addiction
through severe illness through a life
crisis and they come out grateful for
what they've learned that's always law
inspiring and surprising yeah thank God
for that well maybe as a final sort of
topic because I find it always
fascinating when it's spoken about is
the causes of disease hmm okay
so um
if one is going to be scientific about
it one has to hesitate about talking
about single causes you know like it
takes tobacco smoking and and it's very
cigarette smoking and lung cancer okay
if
it is cigarette smoking the the cause of
lung cancer
it seems like it is but the answer isn't
because if cigarette cause smoking was
the cause of lung cancer then everybody
who smokes should get lung cancer
if a is if a is the cause of B every
time you see a you should see B
if when you see a b doesn't show up then
a can't be the cause of B naught is it a
major contributing factor sure as heck
it is 95 of people with lung cancer are
smokers
so smoker is a major contributable
against you but you can't say it's the
cause
Fair yep so so for most conditions
there's a whole
bunch of cards now one of the Lesser
known causes or con I shouldn't say
causes about converter contributors to
lung cancer for example is the emotional
repression
and people repress their emotions
because their anger wasn't accepted as
children they had to suppress themselves
they also suppressing their immune
systems now to most doctors it sounds
like crazy talk but that's only because
they haven't looked at the scientific
evidence when we Progressive emotions
we're actually messing with their immune
systems so a major contributing factor I
don't say because
but a major contributing factor to
illness is emotional repression and
for example if you look at autoimmune
disease
like rheumatoid arthritis or Scleroderma
lupus fibromyalgia
multiple sclerosis
70 80 percent of people with Autism
diseases are women
and who are and who are the ones in this
culture who are programmed to repress
their anger and to serve the needs of
others is women
and in my contention that's a major
contributor not only is it my contention
I can and do cite all kinds of
scientific evidence to show that so when
you talk causes we have to look at the
multiple things obviously there are
causes in the environment I mean we live
in an environment
that's so full of toxins and pesticides
and who knows what we you can't even
keep a track of it you know
um
dietary factors obviously contribute you
know the unhealthy diets that people
in this Society often
consume you have to consider that as a
you know what I'm interested in is
something that's largely ignored in
medical
practice or the emotional and
psychological factors that can be
contribute to illness
and for which there's a lot of evidence
so when I talk about these things I'm
not saying that these are the cause
think then they're amongst the causes
but the important ones and the
reversible ones so emotional repression
being inauthentic not being in touch
with your emotions uh if I look at
my own experience as a physician and
then I looked at all the studies which
nobody told me about medical school but
they are out there published in major
journals by the way so this is not mumbo
jumbo medicine I'm talking about there
are four characteristics of people that
get chronically oh that I noticed
people that automatically and
compulsively serve the emotional needs
of others while ignoring their own
okay number one
number two number two a compulsive and
rigid identification with role and Duty
and responsibility rather than needs of
the self
you know so um
that's the second one
the third one is the repression of
healthy anger
happy and anger is a boundary defense we
have to have it
the emotions serve as a boundary so does
the immune system when we repress
healthy anger we're actually messing
with the immune system and again that's
not my fantasy that's what the studies
show that you enter Because and this is
because then you know I could talk to
you about this for a whole day but to
encapsulate it mind and body can't be
separated so the big one of the huge
mistakes that Western medicine makes
is it ignores the science that shows the
mind-body unity and it's all one in fact
why they do that
because this culture separates mind from
the body and medicine is part of the
culture because doctors are not trained
in this despite all the science because
doctors themselves are very traumatized
people very often very driven I mean if
you look at article in New York Times
yesterday doctors have almost the
highest burnout rates of all professions
they have an earth they they there's an
early death rate with doctors even right
I that may be true I don't know but what
I can tell you is when you look at the
markings of Aging in medical students
they age faster than their other people
their age
so doctors are just simply not trained
to understand themselves how would they
understand others you know and
there was a revered medical teacher at
Harvard
whose name is soma voice he was so
revered that to this day at Harvard
University they were Memorial Day in his
honor
okay any thought in in the 1930s and in
1938 some of ice gave a lecture to a
medical school class which was published
in a journal of the medical and Medical
Association
in 1940 and he said that emotional
factors are at least as important in the
causation of illness as physical ones
and they must be as important in the
healing of them
he said this in 1938
four years ago a physician right now at
Harvard is still there
very well known told me that talk about
mind-body health at Harvard is to
jeopardize your career
he says it's changing but it's still
very difficult
so I'm telling you medical culture is
like no since summer wise made that
statement in 1938 there's been what
eight Decades of research showing the
mind-body unity and that's almost
completely ignored in medical uh in
medical training so
no wonder then that is emotion given the
Mind Body unity and the insurpable
um Oneness over emotional apparatus with
our immune system and our hormones and
our nervous system when something
happens emotionally of course it happens
physiologically it can't be otherwise so
the final characteristic of people that
get ill and are are people who believe
that very responsible for other people
feel and they they believe they must
never disappoint anybody
and these people with these four traits
it's not magical we're mysterious it's
very stressful to be always serving the
needs of others it's very stressful to
be repressing your emotion you're your
anger it's very stressful to always
trying to please others
these people tend to get chronic illness
a lot of Trapped energy yeah that's
exactly suppressed and trapped energy
now notice I didn't say this is because
I'm saying it's a major contributing
factor and when people get ill they
often learn not to be that way anymore
and often they can heal
you know and um lots of examples of that
as well so well that's what I've learned
in my
both in my medical practice but also you
know through the my past or I should say
my traversal of the vast literature
that's out there well it connects to the
very beginning of the conversation with
um being met emotionally and being able
to emote and be supported and that's
such a loop to adulthood and the things
that we face and the challenges that we
have
um
okay well my last question then is is
really just
a little bit of a more of a spiritual or
philosophical question which is what's
this is hard like being human is hard
um I think that there are I think that
it is
you know I I originally if you'd asked
me what what I thought the point of all
this was it was to experience Duality
which is essentially going to imply that
there's challenges and there's Joys
pain and joy
um I don't know if I always still
completely believe that but but I think
that there are I think but by Nature it
seems like this setup of an experience
of being a human
um does provide a lot of contrast and
there's a lot of and there's there is
there is pain in there and we can't see
ourselves and we have to it's very
difficult to see ourselves and so we we
get it reflected back from other people
and that can create a lot of confusion
because again you can't see yourself
that well so
really the question is is what's what is
the point of this what is the point of
this
glorious and painful
experience of being a human
the reason I laughed when you said that
it's hard to be a human is because
um I kind of I've said this before
publicly but I've concocted I've written
my own Epitaph and uh on on my
gravestone it's going to be carved it
was a lot it was a lot more work than I
had anticipated what's the point
you know the mind can't answer that one
because the mind can say some wonderful
things about that
um
but
um
I think that's a question that everybody
can only answer for themselves
and I don't think
um anybody can prescribe it for anybody
else but I would venture to think that
you have either
found an answer or at least approximated
an answer that reflects
whatever stage you're at right now in
your life
so
if I said to you is there a point to
existence I don't imagine you'd say no
it's pointless would you or snap no okay
so that means that there's something in
you that is either have found a point or
is convinced or is
confident
that you'll find it you know and that's
not the mind
that's your whole experience you know
beyond the mind and I would say
I could talk about
the point of my existence but I can't
talk about the point of anybody else but
I think
it does have to do for all of us on some
level with this connection that we're
not isolated creatures that this
separate Soul self is not all Theirs to
us and that
the point someone has to do with the
very fact that we are that that we exist
so a point of existence is our existence
and that but but but that existence is
um
much greater than the mind would
ordinarily imagine it to be now
this just something that came up to for
me in response to your question
I don't know if that's the truth or not
but it's just what occurs to me when
you're last night you know
yeah enjoy the ride
yeah well thank you you too
yeah thank you very much I've followed
your work for so long and I was so
excited to talk to you thank you for
getting up early to do it well it's a
pleasure thanks very much thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button